je m'attendais très clairement avoir une
elisabeth bornes qui goûte un petit peu
comme un verre d'eau tiède je trouve que
c'est déjà fondamentalement différent de
la elizabeth bornes que nous pouvions
voir peut-être mi juin
madame la présidente
mesdames et messieurs les députés
en m'adressant à vous c'est à la france
que je parle trop longtemps notre vie
politique n'a été faite que deux blocs
qui s'affrontent
il est temps d'entrer dans l'ère des
forces qui bâtissent ensemble une
majorité relative n'est pas et ne sera
pas le synonyme d'une action relative
elisabeth bornes arrive la majorité
relative se lève les autres restent
assis et ça ça pose des bases qu'est ce
que la confiance en rhétorique dans le
discours et comment construire cette
confiance aristote appelle la confiance
la justice comme l'une des grandes
finalités du discours la confiance passe
par trois canaux le premier canal c'est
l'expérience les gens d'expérience this
plus facilement à la confiance
la preuve scientifique est un moyen de
tisser un lien de confiance est le
dernier canal c'est un canal plus
abstrait c'est la motivation est là je
m'attendais très clairement avoir une
elisabeth bornes qui goûte un petit peu
comme un verre d'eau tiède c'est vrai
que ce n'est pas une grande oratrice et
le dit elle même elle est plutôt pudique
je m'attendais donc à voir quelqu'un qui
partait perdante face à ce lien de
confiance qui reste est à construire
parce que s'il n'y a pas de vote de
confiance c'est que il y a beaucoup de
choses à construire et là je tombe sur
une elisabeth bornes qui n'a pas le goût
d'un verre d'eau tiède qui a plutôt
justement cette apparence autoritaire
motivé avec un rythme ternaire le rythme
ternaire c'est quoi s'est déclinée en
trois temps son propos les français ont
élu une assemblée sans majorité absolue
il nous invite à des pratiques nouvelles
un dialogue soutenu à la recherche
active de compromis
rappelons nous que c'est le gouvernement
rocard qui n'avait pourtant qu'une
majorité relative sur ses bancs qui a
créé le rmi la csg et lancer le
processus de paix en nouvelle calédonie
nous avons encore des droits à conquérir
des progrès à réaliser des protections à
bâtir et le rythme ternaire il est
fondamental rhétorique pourquoi parce
qu'il est je dirais partout liberté
égalité fraternité
le père le fils le cet esprit matin midi
soir yes we can de barack obama le
rythme ternaire est partout et elles
utilisent abondamment donc c'est aussi
une preuve de rythme une preuve de
structure est une preuve aussi
d'engagement dans son discours et rien
que pour ça je trouve que c'est déjà
fondamentalement différent de la
elizabeth bornes que nous pouvions voir
peut être mi juin oui nous devrons
travailler progressivement un peu plus
longtemps
[Applaudissements]
la grande chance à mon sens pour
elisabeth bornes c'est qu'elle a très
vite pu compter sur le soutien de cette
majorité relative c'est à dire que il y
a eu beaucoup d'applaudissements très
rapidement été soutenu ces a
publiquement alors ça peut paraître
anodin mais offre aussi des petites
bulles d'air frais et là tout de suite
pu compter sur cette audience qu'on va
considérer être une audience acquise
elle devient ami avec cette audience
elle tisse ses liens d'amitié maintenant
pour ce qui est de l'audience austin
sceptiques
c'est cette autorité qui répondent à
cette audience hostile à cette audience
sceptiques nous devons aider les jeunes
à déceler et faire éclore ces talents
les adultes à des serait même s'ils ne
sont pas même s'ils ne sont pas dans le
moule
avec nous devrons bâtir un nouveau pacte
répondre à la question des remplacements
avancé pour l'aide individualisée
adapter leur formation soutenir les
projets collectifs
mais il serait illusoire de croire que
les solutions seraient identiques
partout sur tous les territoires et bien
c'est un doute qui s'installe dans la
légitimité de celle ou de celui qui part
et pour répondre à ce doutes quant à la
légitimité
il faut aussi être capable de replacer
sa légitimité le mot ensemble et le
verbe bâtir ce sont des termes qui ont
été abondamment transmis lors de ce
discours nous ne sommes peut-être pas
d'accord sur toutes les solutions mais
nous avons toutes et tous conscience de
l'urgence et de la nécessité d'agir
des français nous demandent de nous
parler plus de nous parler mieux est de
construire ensemble
je veux qu'on semble nous redonnions un
sens et une vertus au mot compromis
depuis trop longtemps oubliées dans
notre vie politique
on le voit bien un ton autoritaire mais
qui intègre l'entièreté de l'assemblée
nationale c'est la bonne posture pour
communiquer avec ceux qui vont plutôt
avoir tendance à vous huer
ça va être à mon sens la bonne manière
de faire
[Musique]